first game of a three-game home stand
for the houston astros it's going to
have brandon belak on the mound we
talked about how luis garcia got moved
up to that start yesterday because of
from valdez being scratched belak has
actually been pretty good in the last
couple of outings he's had going three
innings in his last two outings between
seattle and the angels
throwing 47 and 43 pitches in those
outings
there goes the runner the swing and a
miss the throw by castro will be a
little bit late
rojas picks up his team leading ninth
steal of the year marshall goes down on
strikes for out number one
a little bit low with that fastball
peralta draws a walk
so the diamondbacks have two runners on
with one out
swing and a miss got him with that
slider down and away belak with a big
strikeout there has picked up two
strikeouts in this inning
big pitch count on him in the first
inning and that will be added to with a
walk here to cole
calhoun a little single and a couple of
walks of low to the bases
popped up shallow right field kyle
tucker will come in
and the diamondbacks will strand the
bases loaded in the first inning for
your diamondback starting pitcher
tonight is madison bumgarner gonzo going
through a difficult stretch to close out
the year wouldn't listen his last four
starts yeah you see him there with a
4.66 cra the big thing for him his last
couple starts giving up a lot of the
long balls playing in a small ballpark
here he's got to keep that ball down
swinging a miss on a breaking ball a
good start for madison buff garner
punches that one first base side
walker's got it himself first pitch and
yuli lifts this in the air pretty deep
to center it sends back mccarthy he has
it measured and makes the catch about
three steps in front of the warning
track to end the inning one two three
frame for madison bumgarner and after
one astros nothing diamondbacks now
then he goes to the slider on top of
that two seamer that's a nice
combination for a strikeout brandon
vilac has three strikeouts and two outs
trying to hold up that's a good inning
for brandon belak back-to-back
strikeouts in a one-two-three second
marshall on the ground bregman knocked
it down it rolls into left field
rojas rolls into third
nice job of hitting right there by
dalton varso
marshall for second and he's in there
don't necessarily have to bury it just
keep it off that outside corner there
you go
big strikeout for brandon bilac with
second and third and one out
as he gets christian walker second and
third two outs astros go to their
bullpen blake taylor will take over here
as cole calhoun is due up
calhoun sends one to center field myers
drifts back has room puts it away
one pitch and one out for blake taylor
to get through the third
[Applause]
got that fastball in ahmed is there
throws across his body and they get the
out nick ahmed nicely done
popped it up
who wants it rojas calls off mad bum
ran that one in at 91 and blows castro
away
he set down the first nine no score
after three
nick ropes one down the line that's a
fair ball in the corner
and siri has to go a long way to pick it
up ahmed pulls into second with a
stand-up double
call third strike throws him on an
outside corner fastball that'll end the
fourth inning a double one man left on
base
one more time for rojas they get one got
a hurry here
and they roll it
that'll make up for the e5 a nice five
four three double play for two quick
outs of the fourth
it's as good as he's looked in a while
marshall will give it a chance here
dalton has got it up against the wall in
the corner for the final out of the
fourth inning dalton varshall hauls it
in
and we are scoreless through four and we
expected to see christian javier at some
point tonight he comes in here with a
runner on third base and two outs facing
the right-hander christian walker 2-2
from javier swing and a mess got a
fastball by him in the ending is over
so christian javier gets the final out
of the frame
diamondbacks are over nine with runners
in scoring position tonight
[Applause]
and there's 91 right by him and that
button gets strikeout number three
[Applause]
he's having a nice year this year boy
madison bumgarner has looked really
sharp two outs in the fifth
well he has dominated that outer half
against righties ahmed
quick enough
a one two three fifth man bomb no hits
through five and no score in houston
sixth inning cole calhoun the dh back
from the injured list today
his first game since august 11th
[Applause]
old calhoun gets it up in the air it
backs up tucker still backing up in
right field cole calhoun has gone
got it just over the fence and just over
kyle tucker's glove and the diamondback
strike first there's the run for mad bum
oh a nice piece of hitting right there
by cole calhoun a home run in his first
game back since august the 11th but it's
one-nothing diamondbacks
astros get their first base runner in
scoring positions the astros still
seeking their first hit oh duvets hit
the hardest baseball of the night
against mad bum
hits one high to left field that falls
deep and that ball is gone
on to the train tracks
no hitter over
shutout over
train number 27 has just left union
station it's 2-1 astros
runner third the tyne run now takes
something from van meter
picking ball is throw it's in the center
off the glove of altuve then mater ties
the ball game and walker scores josh van
meter finally breaks through
ball game on the line for the
left-hander joe mantiply second and
third two outs two two ninth inning
way into this he got him carson kelly
holding on to the foul tip and joe
mantifly puts out the fire and gets us
to the tent good enough to move the
runner to third base now with one out
david peralta steps in
that's bounced by guerrielle it's a base
hit for peralta rojas scores and the
d-backs have the lead now donato the
tying run at third alvarez the winning
run at first 3-2 diamondbacks bottom of
the 10th
that ball little looper with the infield
in that's going to be down for a hit
we're tied up at three
jake
myers rbi single the bottom of the 10.
bases are loaded chaz mccormick to have
a moment
hit him ball game over
chaz mccormick hit by a pitch and the
astros win it for the three